what's up man what's up brother hey hey
man hey man
hey man i got so many guys create some
merch with hey man i got so many
messages from people from the hey man
really oh that was so funny i gotta ask
you gary owen
scary but i love talking to there's
something about talking to people who
are
he's a comedian he's not he's not
[ __ ] around with other stuff
he's a big deal too and he's a comic and
so i
love talking to people who are just calm
you know what's funny
that's funny he's like dude i'm doing
tommy t's and i've added a
billion shows he's like you need to do
it dude i'm like god sounds great
i call my agent like dude tommy t's nor
cal
easy flight let's get it going man he
goes
yeah have you been to tommy t's that's
what my agent said too
i go no he goes well let's put this way
would people rather see you do comedy at
the comedy store
or see you do it in like south central
l.a yeah like
what do you mean he goes it'd be like
you doing a show in south central like
your fans are just going to wait to you
at
the comedy store yep they're not going
to come to south central watch you i go
oh it's he goes it's not your crowd and
he's like kept being around the bush i'm
like
so you say it's more of a darker crowd
he's like yes brendan god damn it
it's not your crap my college baseball
coach was this he was
i've told you he's like he was like a
casual racist yeah but he tried to
he would do the same thing if you were
beating he would beat around the bush
one time he told us he was like now guys
uh
because i went to college in texas he
went you know guys uh just you know
the team we're playing next week has a
lot of skill players
and i was like skill players we're all
skilled dude and he was like no no
skill players and i was like he was like
you know five tool players they can
run they can jump i'm like jump we're
playing baseball
who cares yeah he used to call
anybody team that had black players he
would call them skill players now they
get a lot of skill players
well uh announcers in the nba got a lot
of trouble call jen professor because
a white guy would make plays like such
an italian such a fundamentally sound oh
man
so intelligent yeah like well that was
athletic yeah
yeah yeah you got to stop doing that if
you're being called fundamentally sound
that means you play at the ymca yeah so
are you just that token white
guy who gets you know the did you watch
the lakers in the rockets
i don't miss the nba game right now okay
tell my crew so
so was the worst hair probably the worst
hair in the envy of all time probably
how would
him encounter balance for whose hair is
worse i i love that hair with the
headband
it's weird you just don't get rid of it
yeah and then my brother sent me a meme
of because lebron's hair is just trash
it's and jay said this is lebron's hair
you know when you get a
pack of reese's peanut butter cups and
the top sticks to the wrapper
i can't i can't unsee it it might be
typing lebron reese's that is but
yeah jingles his haircut looks identical
but i'll tell you something man no
reese's reese's yeah yeah like as in the
candy yeah
i'll tell you something r-e-s reese's
peanut butter cup where do you
i just never um lebron james pokemon was
himself
there it is oh my god that is spot on
that
is pretty that is not an even bald spot
how great is that
you know what's crazy to me is that he
literally has a billion dollar contract
with nike a billion dollars
yep he has all the all the resources in
the world to fix your hair well he fixed
the front like he got fake hair in the
front
he tried and then he wore a headband and
it like [ __ ] it up but he
i saw it the other day he's got it in
there and then one time he sprayed it it
looked like he's wearing a pittsburgh
steeler helmet do you have
he went travalta and it's strange though
like there it is
hey what's happening how weird is that
then look uh his boy ad was going
dude your head here put that money put
that [ __ ] back on
let me ask you do you think the lakers
are in trouble at all
i i so they they frustrate i had anxiety
and
you know i'm i'm a big basketball fan
yeah maybe because the corona times and
all the pandemics and fires
i had anxiety watching their first game
against
houston rockets because they played so
bad yeah oh they're so [ __ ]
i was in the worst mood and there's a we
have a group chat of malik
justin my brother stevie we just talked
about basketball
and they were and me and malik who's my
opener we're
big la fans and my brother hates lebron
he's just he kept talking [ __ ]
i'm telling you i was in the worst mood
man i was like
like an hour went by i'm like what the
[ __ ] who gives a [ __ ] yeah
yeah but yeah i think they're in trouble
i think because the only reason they won
the other night because their bench went
off
and i don't think you can bank on that
night after night and i think
they won yesterday because i think
houston had like 17 turnovers westbrook
played bad bad do you know what you're
well you know what i'm
what you're seeing when they surren when
harden's out there were shooters
uh la doesn't have the team speed to be
able to cover all they can't play the
short ball so they're trying to play big
ball and then
they're exchanging twos for threes and
hughes is beating them i don't see them
win it i could be completely left
yeah but i think the clippers are a
better team i just i don't see it i
think the only way they end up beating
the
rockets is this in the first half i
would commit
to running the entire offense through
anthony davis
down low i would try to get pj tucker in
the
in a foul trouble i would just pound it
down low and try to get whoever they're
putting
and i agree with you that's why i said
and my brother made a good point he's
like yeah but that's what the rockets
want
they a.d can go off that's fine it is
gonna get his two points
they're gonna exchange his two points
for their threes without a doubt
but if houston's off they get like they
they almost came back but that's why
they're so good at shooting but but like
my thing is you can't
and i obviously am not a professional
basketball player nor a professional
basketball coach but
my thing is you can't try to beat them
at what they do well what they don't do
well
is guard is is guard the pain yeah so
pound
do what you do well because if you start
to los who's gonna who on the lakers can
launch it with the rockets
no like three point one no no no one
really none of them i mean they were
hoping kuzma could but
but he's hot and cold see my thing is
they win if like the bench plays well
but yeah
random man i don't think he can win a
championship banking on that i don't
think morris is going to hit he was
stressing me out yeah
and the east is random as [ __ ] yeah
boston now it's tied with the raptors
i know then you got milwaukee and miami
what's the deal that's random dude
i'm so stunned by how poorly milwaukee
played in the first couple games
but how well like is jimmy butler
that good monster people don't realize
like he's the secret sauce i guess
with the philly was like oh we're fine
with bj
in bed we're fine with those guys and
then butler leaves like oh we're not
fine he was the secret sauce on why
we're winning the playoffs
he goes to miami now they're the secret
sauce so it's like he's the guy dude
you know he's such a monster they say in
the gym like just
outside five on five but one-on-one he's
literally unstoppable
really like the best one i want him and
russell westbrook are supposedly the
best one-on-one players in the nba see
to me
do you want your best player to have
that kind of grit
his k he's a killer it's one of the
reasons why i never
and i could be the only one i i openly
admit
russ uh that james harden might be not
might be
is one of the top three unstoppable
offensive players i've ever seen
yeah i hate watching him play how come i
hate his games
i don't know it's not that fun though is
it right i don't i don't like people who
game the system
like you know what i mean like you know
how he gets a zero step and they always
get the yeah who's just the fouls
yeah i agree i mean unstoppable you look
like 45 points yeah i don't remember
that but then you watch jimmy butland he
goes off
yeah the other thing is too is when
there's five minutes left jimmy butler
takes over he
he give him the goddamn ball if you
don't he's gonna be pissed
lebron passes with five minutes he'll
pass i'm like
there's how you like this dude there's a
chance lebron james when he retires
will be the leading scorer of an all
time and be a top five assist dude
well i think he's four yeah five or four
in uh all-time assists right now already
and
i think he will be the leading scorer if
he stays well yeah
how crazy is that man and still people
will argue that he's not that good
in that banana well the argument is he's
not the greatest of all time but
anybody with a break you can't argue
he's not but saying that
you're not michael jordan is like is the
craziest
insult of all do you know what i mean
like it's the nobody's michael jordan
and but nobody's lebron either no he's
the closest we've come
lebron's more like magic their size and
stuff like that's just that's a better
comparison like the way you can pass
and [ __ ] yeah i agree the one closest
thing to michael jordan would be kobe
because the killer instinct no
the closest you're gonna get and he
played good defense i like that's a
better comparison
i loved even as a boston fan i just
loved watching kobe i love watch it's
why i love russell westbrook
i love the step on your neck guys yeah
me too i really do like when they get
fired up yeah
man you're like oh hell yeah when you
see russell westbrook the first game we
started talking [ __ ]
he was just talking [ __ ] to guys i'm
like oh man when you see westbrook on
the bench
you see him on the bench and you look at
his eyes it's so intense
he and kobe was the same way they look
like oh i can't
just wait to [ __ ] somebody else i love
that
fire i love it too but i think jimmy
butler's got a two it's one of the
reasons why i think
like i think you need like guys like pj
tucker
and westbrook hardin doesn't win without
gritty dude no because he's not although
that
last second block was pretty impressive
yeah he did close out quick
rare yeah and now that you're watching
basketball are you excited for the nfl
on thursday night
did you know even though the nfl starts
on thursday night i had no idea
that's a problem chin did you know nfl
starts on thursday night before i told
you i'm below the belt i wouldn't know
it anyway
you know not that you guys really
followed me uh i did know my sister told
me
wait she's the first full weekend this
weekend yeah
and thursday nights hold up dude
thursday night's kansas city chiefs
vs houston texans ridiculous no idea
that's
and that's like you know if you listen
to sport radio everyone's like man we
don't know how this thing's going to go
because nobody knows it's happening
you know part of it is because i guess
pre-season yeah you hear so much of the
usual pre-season
and and and there's guys hype around
training camp no
when usually like hard not i love hard
knocks literally my favorite show
one of them but it's like it's been so
coveted heavy and there's
nothing going on literally the last 10
minutes of to
the second episode it showed them
playing cornhole with like
dope music but in slow motion i was like
oh
no they have nothing
like you have you've been watching the
past 10 minutes these guys playing
corn hole in slow motion cool music but
they're all
yeah for 10 minutes i'm like oh [ __ ]
they've ran out of material yeah
and cool music by the way it's cool for
the first two minutes
who who named it cornhole
that's the worst like do you want to
play cornhole sounds like
you're asking somebody can i stick my
dick in your it's very weird
cornhole and then also is that the
worst-named game portal [ __ ]
there's not even a close and how do i
smear the query probably be worse
yeah you can't play that anymore
you can call something else yeah but you
can't play that oh
try try try bring it up in a like a hey
kids want to play smear the queer let me
know what goes with the other parents
i will tell you that you can't play
dodgeball or red rover dude
no red rover is gone red rover red rose
but so fun hey fam are you sick of cable
well i am too that's why i'm switching
to fubo tv for live sports news
prime time tv without the complicated
contract
of my cable provider see ya man it's
time to
cut the cord do you love watching tv but
hate your cable company well i do too
it's time to pay less money for more
channels all right
uh the monthly cost of cable is
sometimes over 200 bucks easily
fubotv is 65 a month to watch the same
damn channels and you don't have to pay
for dvr
or installation it's super easy
fubo tv is how you should be watching tv
you get everything you want all in one
place and it's less than the cost of
cable right get hundreds of channels
channels cloud dvr
no hidden fees you can stream your shows
just like you do on your tv or any smart
device
we got you covered man they have major
broadcasting cable networks
so you can find all your favorites all
right we got everything there's no risk
to try it out
get full access to fubotv
for seven days free they have nfl
nba mlb nhl premier premier league
that college sports they got it all
there's no changes man
if you're used to your lovely tv you can
do it for cheaper right now
try it for free risk free all right and
right now
fubo tv is offering you guys seven days
free trial
and 15 off your first month by going to
fubotv.com
fighter there are no contracts you can
cancel anytime you want go to fubotv.com
fighter 15 off your first month in free
trial
that's f fubotv.com fighter
oh it is if you're a sports fan it's
time to celebrate that's right football
is finally here this
thursday kicks off the football season
baby
it's time you got the kansas city chiefs
versus the houston
texans draftking sportsbook america's
top rate sportsbook app is giving all
the users a no-brainer start this season
if you haven't tried draftkings all you
got to do is go to the app store right
now you don't want to miss this
they're doing a cool thing draftking
sportsbook has moved the spread to
kansas city plus
101 points for all users so even if
kansas city loses
by 100 points you will still win big
with the draftking sportsbook
that's a no-brainer plus draftkings is
giving away up to 100 million dollars in
prizes to all users
who enter their free football survivor
pool
all you have to do is sign up for
draftkings sportsbook enter the survivor
pool
you'll instantly get a share of up to
100 million dollars in giveaways so
download the top rated draftkings
sportsbook app now
and use the promo code fighter to take
advantage of this no-brainer of an offer
that's promo code fighter to get in on
all the action
you got nfl thursday you got bellator
friday bellator saturday ufc saturday
got nba playoffs
you got premier league soccer you got
nhl nba
mlb you got it all nfl
starts this week baby make money all you
gotta go
two is draftking sportsbook promo code
fighter get in on the action
must be 21 or older new jersey indiana
or pa only
eligibility restrictions supply see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 1-800 gambler or
in indiana 189 with it
dodgeball was good here's my thing about
best do you remember in all of us and i
used to talk about this on stage
but it's one of the few things that
really bonds us all together
everybody in here and everybody
listening remembers
what the red rubber tastes like when you
get hit in the face you know remember
that noise that bank
and you could hear it and everybody in
the gym went oh the one off the face
oh and everyone's like oh and then
remember getting hit by the ball
and trying to walk off the court and
getting hit like nine other times
i'm out god damn it i'm out or when your
buddy would catch the ball yeah like
you're
free-for-all everybody back in you're
like yeah dodgeball was great
i also think dodgeball i understand i
guess
theoretically why they had stopped
playing it i don't understand but
i guess i i do not understand they
politically correct i don't
understand i agree with you to me in a
real-life world
it's important to be out on the
playground and realize
okay there are people who are better at
that than i am but i'm going to do this
but i'm going to do that
there so oh i still want to play that
even though i know i'm going to get my
ass kicked that's my favorite game like
it's important but that's how you can
get better at this yes
like it's it's all right i'm not the
most ass like but i can out calculate
these kids and hang in the back
uh i doubt i told you i think i've told
the story before
i was in it was my freshman year of high
school
so sports was my life football
everything and i was uh weekend
prior snore snowboarding with my buddy
they dared me to jump off the ski lift
like we saw in like when as you were
going up yeah like jump off and on my
board and come down
well i'm not [ __ ] trip i'm not zander
you know from triplex
yeah so i jump off well i didn't land
like on my board like the movies
i landed on my collarbone and blew up
shattered my collarbone
so i'm going to brace during how far
does it drop just out of curiosity i
don't know
far and that and that they're like oh
it's powder snow so you'd be fine
not powder snow yeah that thing was it
was a glacier you're also
not 140 pounds i was at the time oh
really in high school that's probably
140 maybe 150
oh [ __ ] how small i was a late bloomer
so i blow out my collarbone i'm gonna
i'm gonna sling and uh they they play
dodgeball and gym in the wrestling room
so they're all dodgeball we all have our
shoes off and so i was just sorry my
move is i'm just gonna dodge everything
so i'm dodging everything i can hit
it comes down to me and three other kids
but all the balls are on my side because
i'm just dodging not throwing
and then i'll never forget the fat girl
in the corner goes
because i can't throw because it was my
right hand and i can't laugh this
is a nightmare they would catch in the
game would have been super funny to
watch
dude so the fat girl goes kick it
i was like oh brilliant idea i looked at
the coach i'm like can i kick it the
teacher he goes for sure so i line the
balls up and the kids are like brandon
brand down like here goes nothing i go
to kick and my big toe
i just it's like squishy i go to kick my
big toe
hits the mat first oh dude
oh my god dude i shattered my big toe
[Music]
so they rushed me to the hot they rushed
me to the doctors
and the doctor goes yeah it's broke and
i go oh man
okay what are we gonna do guys nothing
just wear sandals yeah for like the next
few months
and your collarbone dummy uh dude yeah
like this
all [ __ ] up they are [ __ ]
i can see the slow-mo in the movie too
with the great music oh dude
and then gunk oh oh dude um
do you know what i i think it what
they're doing to kids
in gym and at recess is wrong do you
know there's some
uh this was a couple years ago and
they've they've pulled back a little bit
but they were people who wouldn't even
let kids jump rope in gym with real jump
ropes because they didn't want one kid
seeing that another kid was better at
jump rope so they just jump roped with
fake jump
how that's going and how's that going
how is society so
[ __ ] you know that does creates mass
shooters it's so dumb
they're [ __ ] idiots the first time
you realize that you're not as good
at something as somebody else you hit
the hook can't be when you're
figure it out i look not everything is
for everybody
this is a great example not everybody's
super smart you know the
[ __ ] wildfires out here were
supposedly caused by somebody doing a
gender reveal
party for whatever reason this happened
it happened in arizona
but can i say first of all you know what
happened to the guy in arizona he got
the 200
000 fine two hundred thousand uh
i want everyone to listen to this very
specifically is this the camera that's
it
hey is that my camera nobody gives a
[ __ ]
what gender your baby's gonna be no you
don't need to throw parties not
oh listen the only i don't if it's a
race reveal party i'll go like if you
have a black guy an asian guy and a
white guy
that'd be cool and the woman's like
we're going to hit the balloon
i would i would watch that i would go to
that party yeah but if you invite me to
a gender reveal party
we're not friends anymore no i remember
all we all we did is my uh
brother-in-law stephen brought over a
cupcake
and we bit into it but but listen even
that was a little much for me
i thought i was like i don't i don't
mind you just celebrating your finger in
it
but i don't mind celebrating you're
having a baby good for you i
don't give oh [ __ ] what sex your
babysitter
technics to release the [ __ ] gender
[ __ ] yeah
how self-important do you think you need
to invite 50 people over you know what
you don't have [ __ ] else going on
it's so dumb you don't have [ __ ] else
going on you got to throw a party
with pyrotechnics and you know what is
even worse there
and who was like yeah let's do it out
here in the middle and we know it's hot
in the summer
and let's have some firecrackers and how
about b how about the people who
like the the guy who hits the balloon
and it's pink and he's visibly
disappointed i'm like yeah bro your kid
is gonna see that
well how about the your kid is gonna be
like you didn't want me well how about
the not at the moment
how about the dumbass when they toss
them the balloon and he strikes out
i mean it's and it breaks on the ground
and they're like oh it's a boy yeah
it's so well dude how about how about if
let's say you're doing a gender reveal
party
in the mountains and you started a fire
that costs millions and millions of
dollars in tragedy and killed lies
that baby i mean it's just not a good
sign what are you gonna name that baby
diablo yeah and fuego
yeah it's influential yeah you have to
do something with fire it
it's so dumb the the
baby business and what is available for
babies and what parents do and what they
buy
to me is so over the top the amount of
money that people pay
on their kids birthday parties over the
top can you imagine
your dad setting up a camera in your
room because he wanted to watch you all
the time
just just as a matter of fact when he
went into your room i'm going to tell
you what he was thinking
thank god i don't get to talk to that
[ __ ] guy for until tomorrow 100
that's what we were all thinking but no
but you know now we have cameras in the
room because
kid cries something like that it's crazy
dude it's
all access all the time and i just i
don't think it's good
for parents or kids that's not healthy
separation is
is a little bit yeah you know what i
mean but then also like my son he
keeps waking up at like 4 30 5 a.m and
i'm an early riser so i don't mind it
but then the other morning he walked in
the room and woke me up
and i was like all right here we go and
i was kind of rested and i got all my
[ __ ] together we're going to get
let's go downstairs and make coffee like
i'm walking down i look at my phone it's
1am
i was like the hell are you doing dude
does he like making coffee with you yeah
he loves it
that's awesome so i go dude you gotta go
back to bed it's like it's one tiger
you gotta wait till at least five he's
like oh okay and then the next one i go
dude
why keep getting up so early man he goes
i don't have a clock yeah
yeah i don't have a clock i went
oh wait yeah you don't do we noticed
yeah i don't have a clock man i was like
well we're gonna get your clock cuz how
would i know what time it is
i go we can't tell
when i get up i get up dude you haven't
taught me how to tell time
to get up at six he's like i don't have
a clock yeah it could be right now you
can't tell 12 i don't know what time we
got on the clock when it's time for him
to get up it turns blue
i'm like do not get up before that clock
turns blue
i don't have a clock that's i don't have
a clock is one of my so funny
one my favorite matter of fact thing
that my daughter ever said to me and
kids say matter of fact things where
you're like oh that's right
yeah so when i first started dating beth
um i was single i was raising three kids
and my rule was
you can't meet the kids until i know
we're in a serious relationship yeah you
can't i never quite understood people
like we had a first date
cool let's meet my kids because i don't
know if i like you
i certainly don't want you having any
relationship with my kids
or my kids to somehow get attached to a
nightmare
right so like like i never wanted my
kids to see revolving door of women
i didn't want my sons to think that's
how it was supposed to be and i didn't
want my daughter to think that
right when when i was sure something was
supposed that was going to happen with
this woman
is when i would introduce him right now
so one night beth used to come over
and she would drive home at night i was
living in sherman hope she was living in
west hollywood
and um one night she was like i'm too
tired i just can't drive
and i said do you want me to uber or not
uber back then but you want me to call a
cab
i'll and then i'll catch you back here
and we'll get your car but
the first time my kids meet you can't be
in my bed tomorrow morning like that's
not
and she said well you have a walk-in
closet do you mind if i sleep in there
gangster
and i said what she said i'll sleep in
the closet i said let me see if i get
this right
you're gonna come over we're gonna have
sex you're gonna sleep in the closet and
she said yeah and i was like wifey
yeah i said okay yeah wifey and by the
way that this went on for a couple
months i put a mini fridge in there
would you sleep in the closet she would
just go sleep in the closet it was
dude it was so she's awesome
so then one morning my daughter comes
into the kitchen
and she goes down and my deal with them
in the morning was i'm gonna make
breakfast but you guys gotta get
yourself dressed i can't so you know
when you let your kids get dressed they
put on the [ __ ] they look like
[ __ ]
the crate like serious clowns so you got
a tutu and overall they all dressed like
yeah jaden smith it basically you're
going to put on every article of
clothing you have yes
is that the move it's crazy yeah you
have socks on your hands do you not
realize what colors matter it drives me
nuts no it's crazy
but she she came in the kitchen she said
um hey daddy i can't find my shoes and i
said babe
you know the deal i'm making breakfast
and lunches you got to get yourself
dressed
go check it out so she comes back a
couple minutes later and she says to me
i still can't find my shoes and there's
a stranger sleeping in your closet
smart and i said uh okay i said okay
babe
i'll go uh let me check on that she's
about to walk out i go just out of
curiosity babe
there's a stranger sleeping in my closet
and that's the reaction i get
and she just looked at me and she goes
it's your closet daddy none of my
business
closet and i was like that's a [ __ ]
pretty gangster right there
yeah she was like she was basically out
of my business like
yesterday we uh went out and uh grabbed
lunch
you can only eat outside and where i
live it was the highest
recorded [ __ ] day ever
120. and 120 dude
and there's 118 when we're eating lunch
but you have to eat outside so you
ride a bike yesterday i was riding a
bike but we were eating lunch and
tiger's just sitting there
he's never quite he's all quiet like
staring like this
and he's like why are we why are we
outside eating lunch
and i was like we because everyone had
grabbed lunch i was like oh he's
such a good point why the [ __ ] are we
out here everyone was
miserable miserable i like it when they
say
they're dumb yeah my father-in-law
ordered soup
i was like are you soup
outdoors yesterday and 120 dude everyone
was
not not a good time we took tiger on a
hike on this
i didn't realize i didn't realize
ridiculous i didn't realize we were
gonna have this heat wave i just you
know i don't
whatever i just didn't see the news me
my brother came into town
and me and tiger always go on this hike
so we took my brother on a hike
and we're like two miles in i'm like and
i love heat and
even i was like jesus christ nice man
because we're a tiger
and i'm like how something's up man how
hot is that and i don't have my cell
phone
and my brother looks as he has the apple
watch he goes it says 116. i'm like
oh we got to turn around yeah we usually
go like six miles like we got to turn
around
how are we really like we're with tiger
how was he doing he was cool
he was cool we didn't hydrate enough i
didn't bring water like a dumbass
dad so like we go back we go back all he
had was hot
uh like old chocolate milk which he
devoured which he just found about
chocolate milk yesterday
have you gone to the yuhus no we haven't
gone to uh
those fancy ones from starbucks the
organic one has the red
and the cow on it you know just
discovered chocolate milk that by the
way
whoever drives the kids around get ready
for that car to smell like chocolate
milk oh i know from here on out
can i do does your how are you how was
the relationship with your kids and your
brothers out of curiosity
well they call you know tiger calls him
uncle jay he knows who he is but he's
only been out maybe
three or four times you know they live
in denver and then his aunt i i
anthony my brother's wife uh has never
met boston he's nine months now
and then she saw tiger when he was like
four months old so they don't
but tiger's cool if he's like if dad
says you're okay then you're okay
and then so what you know what tiger do
if he knows you're due
he will run you through the ring or
where he's gonna force you to
play every toy go outside go the
basketball court even though it's 120
out
he's going to run you through the ringer
the day you wake
the the second you wake up at 5 30 a.m
he wakes you up
until six at night i told jay i'm like
you gotta say no at some point yeah he's
like i never see him though so i'm gonna
play him like
all right dude get ready this is all
we're doing because they have no offense
he's not going to stop i i will i love
my favorite age for like kids
that four to six three to seven even
so great because they like to play
non-stop they still have that
pure pure joy laugh if i
ain't the one thing that i tell parents
that i wish i had done make sure you
have a recording of that pure joy
you know that laughter that hasn't been
tainted by anything yeah that is just
just joyful so funny it's it's it's the
best
my favorite i i
i miss that pure that just that pure fun
you have friends though like we have
friends who are comics who are you know
for better words they're not great dads
like god you're missing out missing out
i've done some cool [ __ ] my life where
there was fighting
sold out shows on the road shot a
special i've done cool [ __ ] man
big football games there's nothing like
being a dad
it's so [ __ ] fun yes yeah and it's
like god you guys are [ __ ] up man
and this and you're never gonna get it
back no like i'll get sad thing about my
kids growing older
like you're you're missing out dude that
when jacob
so my my oldest two kids for those of
you who don't know my story
uh i met a woman she had two kids we had
a kid together
i kicked when i kicked her out i kept
her two kids and my kid oh i didn't know
that yeah so my two oldest kids are mine
biologically
but i've been with them forever they
called me dad yep
and but the two oldest ones and her mom
started interacting with the mom was
just like right cool you take them see
ya
um the mom had her own
issues i don't get into her stuff or her
i i for me the mom was kind of like yeah
it's probably better if you take them
yes look man i don't bad mouth hurt or
say anything bad about
her too no dude because she's my kid's
mom
yeah i know why i can't when i hear
people bad mouth
it depends though but you gotta let them
find it out yeah you can't be in public
bad-mouthing your kids mom or dad like
if you're kids
let's say you were gay and your kids
other dad was harvey weinstein we got
bad mouths yes yes
yes that way we yeah yeah but you know
what i mean i get you yeah and by the
way
if you're harvey weinstein's kid i'm so
sorry it's a tough yeah it's a tough
road it's a tough i went to school with
her it was so sad during all of the what
uh stories
wow she went to usc the same year i did
she's attractive
uh yes no to my understanding she was
like attractive but like not
necessarily like hot do you know she had
something about her [ __ ]
yeah wait but she went to school this
when all of the allegations came out in
the cases
out of school because it was just too
much dude
that's not his daughter okay
i don't know if that's the one that went
you're you know what you are cat you're
a nice person
let me be a pretty girl you're a nice
person that
is his daughter the redhead the redhead
yeah
she's i thought the daughter was uh the
top right there
holla but that's his that's that's his
girlfriend his uh
like his ex-wife if you don't
this this picture right here anybody
who's who says i love him for his brain
that is a warlock he is he looks like a
straight
up monster there is nothing
redeem like if you show me a picture of
that oh my god
that that that is there you know what
that is that's when you're very
successful in hollywood
and and he has a lot of power and women
and men
and men are attracted to power and
that's what happens
he took advantage of that he is a vile
looking human being
absolutely but i think people who are
that terrible
look like that is he dead no he died
he's in jail right
isn't he i think he was trying to get
out because he didn't
oh he was blaming copenhagen yeah yeah
all right he'll be all right yeah man
you'll be alright put a mask on yeah
i india pearl weinstein by the way
i can't believe you went to school with
his daughter can i just say it was like
oh thank you i got them done indeed
weinstein
could not sound like the most half
jewish person in the entire world
i mean that's like not you not you chew
india pearl that is not a yeah can you
imagine
our daughter though and this comes out
and that's like that's my dad
what the [ __ ] i'd have to change my life
because she would have no idea oh you
got it
don't you have to change your last name
oh yeah do you think
a b because like pablo escobar's son
changed his name
to to i mean does he get all where does
that money go
where does that money go since it was a
league i don't know enough about that
when they when that where does that
money go
so because that money was bought with
the legal drug money didn't pay taxes
right they seized all your properties
but his dad was smart and had properties
and i want to say costa rica
which they still own and i i'm pretty
sure they
they go down there if you are say
tomorrow you decide i'm gonna start
selling drugs okay
what drug do you sell and oh do you see
for me if i'm a drug kids are all under
the pills yeah if i'm a drug dealer
i i honestly my deal is this i'm i'm
like how much do i want to make
that's how much i'm going to make i'm
not going to go over that i'm not going
to make be high profile
what can i do to live comfortably and
not were you talking like a smart
sane person yes with like pablo escobar
like the sun talks about goes
we had so much money my dad was hiding
bearing money
we we had so much we didn't know what to
do with it it's like
i always thought why not stop but he was
so addicted to the life
yeah because it was more about the life
but it's like even el chapo like they
get to certain points like
just take your money right off the
sunset dude and right wait don't wait to
get famous
[ __ ] out i had read something crazy that
like you know who
i don't interrupt you know who's really
good about that jewish mafia guys yeah
because italian mafia the mexican cartel
they're the worst
um you know a lot of these other mafias
and cartels
they they get their family involved in
it because they trust them you know what
jewish does they don't let the family
get involved they take the money
and they put it in actual businesses and
then they pay for the call their kids
education
and their kids are out of the business
dude that's jewish for you my brother
did i ever tell you this you know my
brother went to jail for selling drugs
no really okay but what kind of drugs he
broke
this rule so his rule used to be
i sell to people i know i just am a
small time
i'm just doing it super small time to
stalk away from people stock away some
cash and
it sounds like you have pineapple
express put a little money away right
so this guy that he knew that we all
knew
and he i guess he'd been selling for and
and my brother lived in a little
apartment down off of hollywood like
you know um and kept a pretty small town
like i said
it was almost you had to get a reference
small operation small operation
coke some pills who would he get it from
the ecstasy
well right so
he one time this guy we both we all knew
was like hey can you
get me this amount and my brother was
like you know i don't deal in that
amount
because that amount is a felony yeah he
always kept right he never dealt with
whatever it was right yeah and the guy
was like i just needed this one time
this guy
so my brother who we knew this dude
was like okay just this one time
so he got the amount that put it into
like
a much bigger case he got in his car to
bring it over to this guy we both knew
and he said he
was in his car getting ready and he
looked in his rearview mirror and there
was all these cops flying down the
street and he was like well i'm gonna
let them fly by me
and so he was just on his phone he's
like i'm gonna let them fly by me
and then he said he looked up and they
were all outside of his car
jesus guns drawn get the [ __ ] out of the
car get the [ __ ] out of the car get the
[ __ ] out of the car older brother or
younger
all my brothers are older the one time
that he went above this amount he was
like i get set up
yeah and i and i broke my own rule but
he went how long did you go away for
he went away for a little bit man but it
was weird have you ever visited
anybody in jail never i've i've done a
tour of uh a jail
i did a tour of guantanamo we went down
to guantanamo
it's so intense oh dude have you been
down there never oh
my [ __ ] god so we went down
i went down with chelsea chelsea and
me chris rangiola sarah kelowna and the
the uso had reached out and said will
you guys come down to guantanamo a lot
of people don't go to guantanamo
because it's not kind of the flashy
there's not you know what i mean it's
not afghanistan and iraq and yeah it's
not as flashy
the last people had gone there before us
was beau vice from american idol oh wow
yeah that was the last person who's like
beau bates restaurant i've had in two
weeks really that which is
probably this is so strange very spicy
new album dropping
yeah he's got a google alert he was like
bing twice hell yeah
um guantanamo was because they gave us a
tour of all those prisons
they gave us gave us a tour of the old
one and gave us a tour of the new one
they they're fascinating right can you
believe we do
we put humans like we're gonna look back
on this like what the [ __ ] were we well
you know i would tell you and i'm and
whoever is listening
i'm sure you have fans down there so i
may get this wrong
but in prison no yeah you have some
fandom yeah
the but they the first one when they
sent people down there they weren't
ready to have prisoners they just had
these cages oh no
so when they were having these prisoners
dropped off it wasn't
it wasn't ready for they're like in
kennels they were
and and the guy who gave us a tour was
like yeah we did we weren't expecting
but we had and he said you know the
guards were out here too and you look at
the conditions they were crazy
they had built then they built a new
prison
we went to the center and we saw where
everybody
there was and i was asking him i'm like
is that a playstation
is he eating cheetos and drinking pepsi
strange and the guy said yeah i said why
are you doing all that
and he said we found when we gave him
playstation they stopped throwing feces
at us and i was like
give him playstation yeah yeah let him
play crash bandicoot but they were
throwing
like when they were playing they said
when you walk by the the
the yard they're playing soccer and it's
chain-link fence but you know it's
obviously covered with
plastic so they can't see us walking by
they said don't
don't make a lot of noise you're walking
by the field because people will lob
[ __ ] over the fence at you
jesus christ yeah man i did it once it's
so intense
bob [ __ ] no i wish i did a tour of a
jail and it's
so intense dude and they had to sit down
because me and my boy klopp
for we were in some criminology class
and that was part of the thing
but we were playing like at texas a m so
we missed the field trip
so she was like right you passed the
class but you got to go on your own so
we set it up when our boy's dad was like
a judge or something he set it up
so we went down to this prison it was
kind of in denver dude
it was so intense and then they're like
we want you to sit down with an inmate
he's a he's he's always here
he's been in there like nine years some
[ __ ] and he goes tell tell us your
takeaway from it
so he sits down he's like you know he's
a cool dude and his story
it was always it was never his fault so
they're like
the guard was controlling the interview
he was alright tell him the first time
you're in here he's like man i was just
walking down the street
i was just a black dude they pulled me
up you know walking over they put me on
the ground
and uh he was like and then they they
planted drugs on me man
and they put me in and i'm like damn
that sucks he's like right and he's like
and then the
guy kicks him he was telling the second
time he's like so i get out right
and i'm driving my car i get pulled over
randomly pulled over
they find [ __ ] drugs in my trunk man
again set up twice
i was like dang twice that's weird and
he's like right [ __ ] nuts man
and he goes tell him the third time
you're in here third time dude so i'm
with my girl right man
me and her fighting she calls the cops
they arrest me [ __ ] again they
planted drugs on me and the guy's like
all right that's enough take him wiggles
you see the problem here
he takes no accountability for taking
drugs yeah
and he was in there like eight times
that fourth time everyone was over my
yeah and they busted in they put heroin
up can you believe it every story yeah
he was like you believe this [ __ ] man
he's like you gotta stay out of here
and then they took us they call it the
thunderdome and you walk down it's just
like the worst of the worst and they're
just yelling the
worst like oh [ __ ] you blah blah blah
like jesus christ man
how it was so intense i would not do
well
i was gonna ask you i know for a fact
anybody who's ever watched
a prison movie or survival stuff you
always go
i wonder if i could right i don't you'd
never wonder if you when you're
in a said you wouldn't happen i would
adapt i'd probably commit suicide if it
was if it was like
what's your prison move suicide no
what's your prison what's your move in
prison what's your move so tell me do
you
you do you grow hair out you shave your
head i have a problem because it's like
am i white am i mexican who do i go with
yeah because
it's all about gangs that run the the
prisons what are you going with
i don't know dude the white people like
the aryan race might get the [ __ ] out of
here bro
the mexican like i don't think so dude i
must 13 like i don't think so but what
about the jew is there a lot of room for
the jew in prison i don't know
you have to go white well i don't have
to shave my head
it's tough i'm gonna have to shave my
head and go super whitey yeah because
because my boy stevie blue eyes did a
seven year stint he was big time drug
runner do you know stevie at all great
dude
seven years he did seven year stint man
and he was like i gotta be honest man i
miss it
he was like if if they would let girls
hang out in there more like it was like
the best he was like what about just
being with your boys all the time i was
like yeah i guess
what yeah he's because yeah what he was
like i missed it man he was like what is
it
the just the like the team atmosphere
and he's like
he was just like we were boys man like
every morning like he was like
it wasn't horrible they took care of me
and yeah he was like he was dope
i i yeah i mean listen i i guess i would
just
you know maybe just start go to the y
and start hanging out with some people
yeah you know what i mean yeah you get a
better group of friends yeah maybe join
a group
yeah start a facebook thread join yoga
yeah
there's something you can do to combat
that i i have never
i do i know i wouldn't do well i would
definitely not do well
in prison i would adapt i just don't
know i think i would volunteer to work
in the library in prison that in movies
that seems to be the place to go
oh for sure teach a class maybe you get
out faster you teach your class is that
right yep
if you have a skill and you teach you'll
get out faster i
i would try to teach a class i would
basically
and for sure i've also thought of like
because when i was younger
you know my brothers used to do terrible
things to me and i learned really
early on like if something's gonna
happen you should just let it happen
like my brother used to fart in my mouth
and i used to punch him and we'd fight
but he was so much bigger than me sure
i was just gonna get fart in the mouth
anyway foghorn we call it yeah right so
right so and the old foghorn and so for
the first couple months i'm fighting and
then after a couple months
i was just like wait i can either get
the [ __ ] beat out of me take it
and get a fart in the mouth or just just
getting a fart in the mouth just farm
the mouth
but like those people like let me ask
you this
because when your kids growing up did
they did the the brothers fight a lot
physically my older son
was too much bigger than my youngest but
how much older
he well 92 and 97. so five years that's
a big age difference that's a big
me and my brother were 18 months so we
fought like cats and dogs now that i'm a
parent and my mom
i know you're listening to this mom but
it is what it is they didn't do a good
enough
job not not let my brother beat me up it
was a real [ __ ] problem man
like and it triggers me because you know
my one son's nine months and my other
son's
four so it's a big age yes but even like
it's not he's not mean to him but like i
won't tolerate any of it
any of it if if he were to if they were
to fight i would stop it so [ __ ] fast
my mom and my dad were like you guys
have figured it out and it gave me a
certain skill set which was good like
toughness and heart and all that because
i'm smaller than him
but looking back i'm like why the [ __ ]
would you let that why would you let
that happen
all the time man i do better my
theory is different i was not like i'll
let him figure it out
because my light like i was terrified
yeah me and my brother close now but i
was terrified dude
all the time my thing is out there
out there with other people let him
figure it out
in here we're on the same team same same
team this is same team this is
this is team wolf or team shob like this
is this is
we're on the same team but i'm sure this
is the way it was in
at your house though like you could say
whatever you wanted your brother and
your brother to him but somebody outside
says it to you or says my brother beat
the [ __ ] out of me but if someone did
mess with me then you have to mess with
the big brother and he would [ __ ] you up
so but it was weird though because he
hated me so at home it was awful dude
but then if someone mess with me outside
you didn't offend me he did you know
my oldest brother was six years older
than me and i was in third grade once
and this kid was picking on me this dude
was large i'm not sure if i told you
this before large
and he was the big and he used to pick
me up and bear hug me and
oh yeah right and i just and i had
nothing i could do and nobody you know
he was the biggest kid in class and
teacher wasn't doing anything and i
remember i mentioned it a couple times
at dinner
and i could just see my brother oldest
brother he was in ninth grade at the
time
just shaking his head the whole time so
one day we come in from recess
and my brother 9th grade and in 9th
grade my brother had john mcenroe hair
like this was the time
sick and wore a headband 9th grader man
and he was sitting there with one of his
friends they're coming from recess and
the teacher's there
and i look at my brother and she goes
can i help you that's my brother i'm a
really good which one is he
y'all wait what i go what he goes which
one who keeps picking on you and i go
him
my brother him my brother walks up and
goes let me tell you something
if you touch my brother one more [ __ ]
time
when i come back here i'm gonna kick
your ass
and the teacher did it the teacher was
like hey you can't and said something
like that and he looked right at her and
he did he said
shut up [ __ ] you did your [ __ ] job i
wouldn't have
come in here he said that out louder
what a game if you did your
[ __ ] was this the drug dealer no
no it wasn't but he would flat out if
you did your [ __ ] by the way this guy
this brother
lives in santa monica and got the [ __ ]
beat out of him
during the protests for trying to
protect the business down here not even
his business oh well
he called me he was like oh i'm in panic
what's going on he goes i just got beat
up by a bunch of
like what are you doing man he goes i
was trying to protect the business i go
was it your business did you go by a
bunch of skilled guys yeah i was like
what
i got beat up by a bunch of skilled guys
kill players
yeah they're really fast and jump hype
what
i mean a bunch of black guys beat jump
now
skill guys beat me up front players man
listen y'all you're bored with your
workouts you're bored of the treadmill i
got something for your ass i'm talking
about
fight camp if you've ever done boxing
kickboxing or thought about doing it
now i can do it from your home man i'm
talking about
something legit you get all the gear
sent to your frickin house
all the boxing equipment along with new
box and body weight workouts released
every week it's the perfect at-home
workout
for anyone men women children families
great for all fitness levels you guys
are gonna love it
all right you can do it with your kiddos
my kid loves to do it
you have access to over 400 different
workouts for all fitness levels you can
get hooked
whether you want hardcore boxing you're
a beginner we got you covered man
uh try fight camp workouts for free just
download the fight camp app
select the workout of your choice it's a
great way to test your trainer
buy now pay later there's financing all
right the whole squad can do it the
whole family
up to five accounts you get a full
boxing gym for the whole family under
twenty dollars per person
fight camp offers uh financing for as
low as zero apr and right now it's a
limited time offer
you can try fight camp for 30 days with
the money back guaranteed just go to
joinfightcamp.com fighter that's right
try a fight camp for 30 days
if you don't love it they'll refund your
money train like a fighter turn your
sweatin
results right now to try fight camp for
30 days just go to joinfightcamp.com
fighter join fightcamp.com fighter oh
the official electric trimmer of the ufc
manscape not only are they the
presenting sponsor of this podcast but
they also
sponsor multiple uf stars talking max
holloway francis sugashon
manscape keeps your favorite fighters
groomed up from the feet
up they get the perfect package 3.0 the
perfect package includes
the premier lawnmower 3.0 trimmer
ceramic
blade and skin safe technology are
designed to reduce nicks or tugs on your
fellas down below don't mix your nuts
all right uh thick boys bike club they
love the crop preserver that's right the
thick boys love it
ball deorder it's anti-shafing
moisturizing capabilities
my thick ass has it on my bike all the
time
and guess what for you international
thickies uk
australia and canada it's time to hop on
the manscape movement man because
we're shipping to you for limit time
subscribers get not one but
two free gifts the shed travel bag uh
you get the high patented high
performance anti-safety manscape boxers
and get 20 off and free shipping with
code fighter 20
manscape.com give your testes the
absolute besties
get 20 off free shipping with code
fighter 20 at manscape.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use codefighter20
don't get bogged to trim your hog with
manscape
um but yeah man i think
i think the the problem is is that once
again we're picking
sides when when we should
one acknowledge that it's okay to be i'm
i acknowledge how difficult it is to be
a police officer
and the majority the incredibly high
majority of police officers are doing
the most difficult job in doing it well
the majority of them are doing a
fantastic job absolutely and doing it
well and
very difficult there's going to be some
bad apple yep there's bad apples in
every aspect of the business when
they're bad apples they have a lot of
power yeah
and just like i also acknowledge man
for me to hear white people go there's
no racism or this isn't true
a stop you're not living it every day no
there are there will always be racists
yeah you're not living you will never
get rid of that no you're not living
it every day and there's racism in
africa between tribes
there's racism in every aspect of life
there any
everyone gets in tribes no matter what
it is there's
difference within the black community
100 percent racism in the white
community there's racism towards jews
there's racism between in the jewish
community there's racism in the
asian community towards other ages i had
unfortunately it's it's in our dna if
you're different that's all about being
different somebody's different than you
we're very tribal it's a shame i had a
hasidic jew which was a
the hasidic jews guys are the ones with
the yeah you know things
tell me because i was talking about
barman getting jacob bar mitzvah
and he looked at me he goes well you
guys and i both my mom and dad are
jewish
he goes well you you guys aren't jewish
it doesn't matter to me what you do oh
well and i was like what do you mean
because i was jewish
and he was like yeah you're not he just
didn't consider me to be jewish
interesting right and he was like and
your son the mom
isn't jewish right and i was like yeah
he goes like so he's not oh well he's
not jewish at all i'm like yeah but i'd
like to get a bar mitzvah he's like
yeah but do whatever you want he might
as well use it might as well be like
judging yeah [ __ ]
i want to fly too but that's never going
to happen so like there's definitely
factions but like
my thing is right now in
our country we're not allowed to go hey
you have a good point hey but you also
have a good point
let's be in the middle middle is seen as
weakness but the truth is
it's not man it's about compromise
compromise comes from a
point of strength and confidence yep
right
like i'm if i'm like oh i gotta believe
everything he has to say or he's gonna
be mad at me
that's weak dude that's not good that's
weakness oh yeah
i mean we'll move on from political [ __ ]
but it's also like
when your vote is biden or trump that's
part of the problem it's like those are
the two
that's my choice i think you and i
should run dude these two
that's the choice like no wonder we have
a [ __ ] problem
this guy don't know where he's at can
barely get through a speech
do you see what i did with the
teleprompter oh my god [ __ ] you know
what
you we gotta vote for that or this
you're gonna be trolling people on
twitter
the worst you you would you you wouldn't
be the commander-in-chief you'd be the
commander kerchief
you might have a future i i was
he dude i think if we i think what else
is interesting too is like
with sports like we're seeing like
ratings are down because they're
bringing
politics and sports like the nba stuff
like that yeah i'm so
curious what the nfl is going to do i'm
so curious there's got to be kneeling
dude
what do you think jerry jones is gonna
go what do you think jerry jones gonna
do
when dak prescott and those guys neal
what do you think he's into i don't know
i don't know again it's the bottom
you're affecting the bottom dollar
they're businessmen
you know yeah so if you came out here
and you constantly talk to
politics and black lives matter and this
podcast just went down
we can't have you into it right it's
about your affecting the bottom dollar
now i might agree with you but we just
can't have it right now that we don't
like your support
what you're doing we can't have it so if
you're jerry jones your business owner
like or you're roger goodell like hey
listen we're going to donate
this amount of money to black lives
matter and we can do
post fights or post game shows on it
that would do all what
we'll donate to all that but we know for
a fact when you guys
do it on air during the game our ratings
suck yeah
so what do you do it's such an
interesting thing because because we
know people are the majority people are
tuning out when you do that like the nba
went
so woke the rings are they've never been
worse
i think part of by the way part of those
ratings are definitely because they've
gone political in part is just because
i think the group of people that they're
really
trying to reach aren't watching a lot of
tv tv
the younger like mike oh no dude jacob
doswell's never been better
jacob doesn't watch on regular tv yeah
but you can find it
that's what i'm saying but they count
those they do they can count those now
let me ask you this but then some other
sports are
you know golf was through the roof yeah
ufc that's true through the roof
digital let me ask you so say i'm jerry
jones
yep and i'm a bottom line dealer i'm
bottom line business and i go if you
kneel it's bad for my business
but the product as long as we're talking
about so the players who are the product
say well cool then go get a different
product
because if you're not letting us kneel
we're not playing
do you think that that's it more
then it's gonna hurt but then it gets
dicey because then
we're not getting the advertising
dollars we're not making revenue so then
i'm have to pay
you can do that but i have to pay you
less so that 150 million dollar
contract well that was based off these
numbers now you want to do this the
numbers are here so we're going to
change your pay
and so so are you still going to do it
if it affects your bottom dollar
i let me how many do you think in the
mba
and the nfl would still continue to do
it if the owners went that's fine we're
going to take half your pay
that's it that's it you know what the
nba did so you know nba if you want to
talk about
rights and they support they get all
their they
billions from china who are basically
the nazis
of the soviets it's terrible that
they're doing the
the hong kong awful terrible they don't
say a thing yeah
lebron didn't say a thing his nikes are
made there space jam 2's gonna be a big
brother he doesn't say a thing you know
why
bottom dollar yep yeah that
that's such a dicey that china thing is
such a dicey
it's really not though thing for me why
it's pretty
if you're for civil rights it shouldn't
matter if you're korean
from hong kong i agree with you chinese
100 black white
still human rights are human rights
whether it's whether you're asian
black white jewish doesn't matter if
you're if you're going to preach human
rights
you can't do it just because it's
convenient over here and then just
forget about over here i know that's
where i checked that's why i'm like
you're not about it but if you're about
it you would say something but but
i look at and i agree with you a hundred
percent in an ideal world
civil rights and human rights should be
blanket for everybody but i would tell
you right now
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care nearly
as much
if my kid is sick or if you're kid's
sick do you know what i mean
i'm worried about here's the truth about
human nature
we're worried about our own house agree
and so
as terrible as it is i think to lebron
and those other in the other guys in the
nba
china is like abs it's like it's like
saying hey paul bunyan's sick oh is he
i agree um paul bunyan means whatever to
me i agree but if you're the nba
and you're bad luck for the nba bad luck
well because they're international
yeah so you only care that's over here i
wonder what percentage of their
money they get from china it's over a
billion dollars is it really
is that is that uh tv tv everything
because i know the jerseys and shits
sell like crazy
they make all the jerseys they make all
the shoes they make all the basketballs
i i you know it's in it weird it's so
bananas and i don't know what is it but
like me and my brother talking about
this
i know some people are turned off of the
nba or if nfl is going to do it with the
black lives mates stuff
i don't if that's what they want to do
i'm still going to tune in that's fine
man yeah i get if that if if you're so
passionate that's what you want to do
it's not you're still going to play
that's fine yeah my thing is honestly
and if i think if everybody out there
was honest with themselves
if you had an entire if you had a huge
platform
and something was incredibly important
to you
you'd mention it you just would man if
something was if you thought something
was so
life and death to you or so important to
the way you live
you'd mention it here's my problem this
is
the the issue with me is now what makes
headlines is someone standing for that's
so crazy
[ __ ] dude dude you know what what a big
shame for me
is you know i have hats with the america
i think i told you this i have hats with
the american flag i have shirts i have a
red hat with a flag on it people think
it's trump
yeah i was walking down my down the
street in
west hollywood american hat mask and i
had
more than one person scream [ __ ] trump
me too
and i was like the american flag now is
not
like that's controversial for me to have
that trump owns the flag
it's so [ __ ] terrible i i
we're in such a crazy time dude we're
like that is a controversial
thing to wear i almost saw a fight in
erwan
and erwan is like this shishi so if you
know what you're honest think whole
foods on steroids more expensive
more exclusive and usually only really
rich white people
and so it's two blocks from my house so
when i get high
sometimes i go down and get dessert and
that's dropped like 70 dollars on
one yeah okay i
saw the craziest
and i'm gonna call it a slap fight
between two dudes
outside of that story yesterday hell
yeah but
neither one of them wanted to let go of
the bag in their left hand too expensive
for real yo they were full-on but
this open hand this open hand slap it
like this yeah coming down hard dude you
got to decide it
no and i it reminded me one of my
favorite rabbit holes to go down on
youtube do you ever
watch slap fights on youtube no there's
a there's a ufc
fight have you seen the one slap dude
they
are some is it the organized snap fights
the the actual competitive slap fights
those are the ones that i've been
watching i can't believe people do them
dude they they just stand there
and not get each other out did you see
there's a ufc fighter this
weekend who kissed his hand and slapped
a guy from dagestan
and it was so insulting he beat the [ __ ]
out of him but he's going
slap dude watch
this intense do a compilation
watch how hard they [ __ ] you've never
watched any of these
i saw logan paul slap a big dude and put
him to sleep
they these people get knocked oh he just
punched him
that is a straight up that was a punch
the noises what
oh no that was a slap and they knock
these are ones
yeah they're kind of bathrooms but i
think they aim is this the knockout
button here
yeah here here so watch and watch how
they just stand there
i don't get the point of it oh you never
can say they
wind up you can't leave your feet and
yeah they take it
and they just get stunned and down
you've never seen these fights dude i i
don't get the good night to you oh
i can't and he's happy that they didn't
get knocked out
there are some this i've never seen one
go more than a couple
slaps and usually they're like these are
big dudes
look at this fight lasted for a long
time that is rugged
i don't know what that was that left his
face in slow motion
what i wonder what they're looking at oh
what is that
pow is that powder that could yeah yeah
it's powder chalk oh
are you not allowed to hit behind the
air because that would really [ __ ]
somebody up
go up a little further let me see if
there's another great knockout in there
can you imagine someone like him going
contest dude they
they the guy crying knock dude there it
is
oh [ __ ] oh good night
like these are legit shots to the face
those are brutal i wonder what the
winner gets 5 000
these are the ones of the best that are
at a bar and people don't know what's
about to happen to them
that little guy
held onto that table for dear life
the do you can see these smell insults
yeah you get well you got to wake them
up sometimes
but i've never seen one where you're
allowed to hang on to
you shouldn't be allowed to hang on to
it oh that might have done it what's the
button dude
what's the button is this the button or
is this the button uh it's like back
here but
you get knocked out when you're when
you're when it goes like this when it
whips like the
other whipping and also if they can hit
back here on the equilibrium yeah
it's bad how come i heard on the chin
that makes sense
that's not the button no it's it's shut
when your brain goes
when you get hit and you get your bell
rung
do you know like where you are
oh yeah it depends how hard it is but
yeah you do for sure and
and and when you look back on the fight
it's almost like a high is it really
yeah
is it harder are things slowing down
is it harder to protect yourself you're
just a little out of it it's
almost like you know when you're like
high almost yeah you're just like a
little like
everything's slower and it's going to be
can you can you
can you when you look back at the fight
is there a period that you don't
remember oh yeah
so there's a chunk of time where you're
like i have no idea what just happened
yeah why not zig instead of that and
during that time
is your brain working but your body
isn't are you like
are you cognizant of oh this is i'm not
i'm getting the [ __ ]
not really what what's is there anything
it's just like a barrage yeah just back
to like it's weird huh
i can't even like because when i it's
when i hear people like commenters talk
about oh that nfl player is a [ __ ] or
that fighter is a [ __ ]
to me just by nature of your in the nfl
or you're you're not a [ __ ] no you may
be less tough than some of the people
in that sport no they're still tough but
they're still stuff right made a mistake
like when i hear people call deshawn
jackson not tough i'm like
look man he's not as tough as some other
people
but he and maybe he doesn't play with
injury as well just different but the
fact that you you get his a competitor
in an nfl game he's a monster
i'll tell you something i would tell you
right now 85
of grown-ups in america or in the world
couldn't take getting whipped down to
the astroturf
just that alone you're being generous at
85. i'd say it's more like 95. just that
just that alone seems like that would
hurt look at corona you think 95
could get tackled to astroturf think
about it you're right
[ __ ] that won't leave that and then
we don't get started but dude
i think people like that astroturf is
basically
pavement it's it's green pavement and so
when you now it's a little better but
when you get
thrown on it and that i almost would
rather get tackled when i see people get
whipped to the ground i'm like you just
get thrown on the
on the cement my man nightmare and no
pads
i did have somebody reach out and say
that they played center remember we were
talking about wearing a cup
and he said i played center and i never
he said he never get hit by a cup
never get hit he said most of times this
dude who was listening
said he got hit in the nuts when he hit
himself with the ball yeah
it's very rare there were cups but they
he he said he would hit himself with
yeah man you hit yourself on the nuts
i'll tell you what i thought some guy
was going to cry
cat set me up because my family's in
town i was like you guys got to try the
best sandwich in the world howlin race
without a doubt it's
the best sandwich i've ever had with
that now and i realize i prefer hot now
instead of medium
so i got eight medium sandwiches from my
family drove down to pick them up but
there was a line
it was 115 degrees at 6 30 at night it
was so hot so we're just waiting in
chinatown yeah chinatown never been down
there uh that's a long way from your
house man yeah
i want that's how bad i want the
sandwiches so we wait in line and the
guy in front of us was waiting longer
than us i thought he was gonna start
crying i thought what a [ __ ] dude
you're gonna cry because your chicken
sandwich johnny the tears in the eye
how long was the line i mean there was a
line but they i just had to go to the
front because i pre-ordered
so it took i don't know where they're
maybe 10 minutes that's the way to do it
you got to pre-order
the sandwich is almost better if it
cools off you know how they get them
here they're better when they cool off
well it is spicier when it the
temperature of the sandwich is hot too
yeah i'm going to go down there next
week jacob's back in town
oh yeah he's coming back from and have
cat hook you up with them
you can't just roll in you can't just
roll in no they have a weird thing with
covid right now
where they're only doing deliveries so
the only people who could go
pick them up are people who work for
postmates
so what i did last time was i went to an
apartment
right next to where the shop is and then
had to deliver
like 20 feet away from me
that's really smart so so that's really
smart it is kind of weird
yeah i mean they let me just they picked
up the eight sandwiches but then the
late it was funny because
my brother's with me you can tell they
don't watch the show but some must have
told her that
i was somewhat famous she's like uh a
long time no see but she's looking at my
brother
she's like how everything's going show's
doing good jay's like
everybody's like what and she's like oh
you love these sandwiches he's never had
him he's like
yeah they're good she's like yeah i knew
you loved him she's like can i get a
picture
all right so there's a picture of her
and jade
one of my it was so great one of my
favorites all awkward like
one of my favorites is when somebody's
been told that you're famous but they
don't know who you are
so they ask questions like how's that
going how's the thing you
you making them laugh i'm like yeah
she's like you're having fun out there
and jay was like wait what
she's like you love these sandwiches
he's all nervous
it's so funny how did you eat now did
you
eat it before you got home no i want to
wait for the
because i have to rush home to put tiger
to bed you know i would i um ralphie may
used to live right behind me oh really
and um well i got some good ralph and
hey stories but my favorite
he was we were going he was like josh
well we're going to jack in the box to
get some jack in the box for everybody
and i said all right so we get into his
he was driving a 4 runner at the time
how long was this oh man
99 we were all just kind of starting and
ralphie was the only one who had a
little bit of dough
might have been 2 000. you're so good
and uh we lived right next to our right
we both lived behind el compadre man
that place was
you know joey diaz was around there jay
moore was always around ron white was
around for a little while monsters
uh how good was jaymore dude but ricky
cruz was around at the time oh really
yep um jesus christ so
uh that's when i used to go that was
around that time when i was going and
we would mean when chelsea handler and i
were going out and doing ecstasy all the
time and
it was a good time dude jesus sounds
like the best of those oh it was a good
time
so but ralphie was like come on josh
we're gonna go get some jack in the box
for everybody
so we go get some jack in the box and he
orders this huge order
and he goes put that in one bag and he
goes here's for another bag
and he orders another order and um
like what's that second bag for he goes
it's for the ride home and i said what
he goes this is
i have my at home food and i get my
right old food hilarious and i go oh
okay
and so the two bags come and we put the
enormous bag in the back by the way the
ride home bag was
not small pretty [ __ ] big and he goes
open that glove compartment
all the condiments hot sauce relish i
love
mustard salsa he was like hammy same
with that tapatio
and so my man he he had the condiments
in the glove box dude
ralphie mae was a generous generous
generous to a fault dude yeah he's
always nice to me i remember me and him
i
i was coming back or i fee or maybe i
was going i think i was going to like
west niagara new york i forget where i
was going somewhere far
and uh it stopped in phoenix and he was
going to phoenix i think to do shows or
something
but we were both on southwest there was
a layover for me and we both sit down
and i'm in
the the right side and he's on the left
he was man we too
and i even realized it was him he was
man we too [ __ ] big to be on
southwest
man and i looked over and you know he's
400 pounds like
we yeah at least my size goes up and
down
yeah yeah it kind of fit i mean yeah
we excuse me sir man okay so here's
another good ralph it made story it was
in nashville
now sarah tiano and i were on the road
together she's great by the way
and by the way as far as roast jokes
she's gonna [ __ ] kill you she should
be she's gonna kill you she had a baby
huh
yes and ralphie mae is down at the show
and he's talking to sarah tiana on stage
and saying things like sarah tiana i
don't know sarah tiana
and justin people are laughing they know
they know ralphie and they
and you know that at zany's in nashville
there's not too much separation from the
stage this far
barely anything right so she said i'm
gonna butcher her joke but
basically she said rafi mae is here
everybody ralphie actually just started
taking yoga so he's soon so soon he'll
be flexible enough to
kiss both of his feet goodbye she was
like because diabetes is coming
and i was like that was a great diabetes
jokes
or was the fans dying oh they were dying
so we went out that night right
and ralphie was um
things were not going well with his with
his ex and um
and uh and she had already i think filed
for divorce and so we're out and
there was a yeah he was with this young
girl and and we're sitting there and
we're at this place at a bar in
nashville i don't remember the name of
it
but i heard this huge rumble
and i was like what the [ __ ] and i
turned around and ralphy had fallen off
the stool
oh man and i was like oh man he goes
josh well help me up i'm like help you
up like let me get help yeah and he goes
man you go to the gym i go yeah but
i go to the gym i get on the tread bowl
i don't lift it yeah
i can't lift you up bruh and just then i
saw
there was the girl he was with who was
sitting on his lap i saw two little feet
sticking out from under ralphie
it was like that scene in wizard of oz
where the where the where the
because you just saw her socks and i
said oh and i and he goes oh [ __ ] is she
under me
right hey there was like some guys like
oh we gotta get her under and so
grabbing ralphie was
a a she was 400 pounds and a dicey
situation it wasn't far enough solid
like
it was you know what i mean like if you
grabbed him it was like okay it was like
kind of
goopy yeah and so we were like let's
rock him
and we'll rock him and pull her out such
a shame so we kind of rocked him
and lifted him up and pulled her out and
when we pulled her out dude
this was exactly which the noise she
made we pulled her out and went yo when
her head came out she went
like she had been under water a little
thing so tiny so i said she
man when she came out her eyes she was
scared she was like
400 people like this so i we get her
calm she's drinking a drink she's up on
a stool we get ralphie up
and i had to ask her i go just let me
ask you a question she goes yeah
i might go what was it like under there
yeah and she goes
it was dark soft and warm
ralphie died from uh was the overdose do
we know
he was a sick dude man yeah if you i
remember i remember
the first i heard of he fell asleep on
stage at the lab factory it wasn't it
was like ammonia for me
yeah but if you look at the pictures
from before his death
like from a week before he literally
fell asleep like he was telling her
he was like doing his like crowd work
and then just fell asleep on the stool
look google ralphie picture ralphie met
ralphie may
uh i don't know how would you go like
right there right before he passes
click on that chances corner ralphie may
died of high blood pressure
those were some of the pictures i think
those are actually some of the pictures
from
right before he passed no that wasn't it
but he doesn't look good there there it
is he was so [ __ ] funny man he was so
funny
and you know what i loved about him dude
he would do
three hours and his the the clubs would
hate it
but i asked him i go why would you do
that much time
and he said man the people come to my
shows don't have a lot of money
so he was like i'm an hour dude he would
do a lot of time dude the people's at
the club
for me like it's gonna yeah i've been to
some clubs and they were like
uh like how long are you doing you tell
them like oh wow like that's
pretty standard yeah we're standard
power standard like well carlos macedo
was here last week and he did three and
a half hours that's torque and i was
like how'd that go and like
people are walking out yeah like after
an hour two hours they're out man
it's it's a bit your bit jerking
yourself off at that point in time bit
of an ego thing
i would rather have people there were
sometimes late show saturday where i'll
tell people going in
i am going to be i'm taking 100
milligram edible
i'm going to be really high you can
leave at any time you want because i'm
going to go
because you're going to go i want you to
know i'm not going to heckle you for
leaving and this is how i tell my crowds
all the time
you won't hurt my feelings i've been
doing this a long time if this isn't
your deal
and you don't like it yeah thank you for
coming you're not going to hurt my
feelings
listen man i thank you dave chappelle
and bill burr my
two favorite comedians on the planet
burr's coming on this is it when is he
coming 9 16 he's coming out oh [ __ ]
can't wait uh i mean burr and chappelle
are two of my favorite comedians
i would walk out after about 90 minutes
yeah
i think after it is it gets gets tough
yeah it's just do you how do you do with
like a three-hour movie
i hate it what's the longest movie you
can do name what what
what's the last three-hour movie well i
mean like lord of the rings like jesus
christ so could you not do lord see i
could do lord of the rings
i can do those larp quest
movies um how about the old school
movies like godfather
deer hunter any of those i could do jfk
that's a long one right
what what's the latest three hour the
lord of the rings was avatar three hours
no they can't really do it because the
attention span is so
low dude what was the last long movie
like that
i don't even know i think you're right
like it seems like almost
the irishman but that wasn't incredible
i like the irishman but that's at your
house you can turn it off you can watch
it
which i did yeah i started last like an
hour in took a break
i i gotta tell you there's some there's
something to me about when i
when i break it's not as
enjoyable when i come back really like
game of thrones
no but when i break okay i don't i can
break
not mid-episode though yeah definitely
not mid-episode so i can't move
mid when i go mid-movie i'm not as
invested when i come back in
this movie to me i could still watch any
day you can pop it on right now
i'm watching the deer hunt avengers
three hours suck my
dick you didn't watch it no that's not
your type of movie no desire
i could marvel i get it i'm not watching
better throughout three hours to tell
that story that makes sense what about
the avengers
green mile's a good movie great movie i
i could probably do in an hour but yeah
you think you could do it in an hour
knock that out in an hour again what are
you cutting out what do you mean an
hour i'm i'm getting i'm getting to it
man ooh titanic
i've never seen it what what it is
probably one of the best movies
how do you avoid titanic i've never seen
titanic i've never seen the notebook
i've never seen either one of those
no book makes sense titanic though i
mean do i need to see it yes it's a good
movie
okay so it's what's the movie that you
haven't seen
that people would that's my titanic like
what's the movie you never saw black
panther and i saw the avengers
everybody saw the wolverines the star
wars saw war
stop saw the old star wars not into the
new ones so anyway
i didn't see any harry potters none of
those
you are you gonna watch them with your
kids if they're into them i will but i'm
not gonna force it on them
may you say sci-fi anything where you're
like that is funny
and stupid no kids in high school um
brooms not into terminator
i mean when you break down harry potter
as kids in high schools on rooms
that sounds funny game right that's what
it is
terrible kids and how yeah but it's not
i mean there's magic
there's magic not into it do you wish
magic was real i do man every time i
watch magic movies i'm like man i wish
somebody could do that [ __ ] it'd be cool
right just one not like a david blaine
like
when i saw that balloon stunt but he
to me like when people told me he's
doing the balloon stunt he's gone from
magic to just straight up jackass
me too like oh you're you just do risky
[ __ ] now
how many magic views like i'm actually
on the ground yeah or
these aren't balloons yeah like these
aren't balloons i was blowing up myself
but he's not now he's just bro he's like
i was i i swam with
great whites for two hours and eight
bananas like any magic
you just got lucky you didn't get eaten
really dumb yes why bananas
i think he's just all out of magic and
he also looks like my brother and he's
just all out of
magic this i i really think i don't know
how many people
were thought to themselves i wonder how
far a blowdart gun could reach
because that that he's just hanging on
by his hand with balloons
i think he's hooked on yeah i'm i'm
so he's flying balloons magic no
and it's not a loser when he asks rogan
to push the
the rod through his bicep yeah what was
not magic
was like there's blood coming out of his
arm was it really yeah they had to take
your tissue and like
pat it so that's not magic that's just
well on air didn't rogan have to tissue
and pat it because it like went through
a
nerve or something like that that's not
magic that's not my thing
by the way i like really weird [ __ ]
but i don't like blood i don't like
like what's the point of that right
there
oh no i'm not into it i'm not into that
stuff at all are you into that
were you into chris angel at all when
that was a hard pass
me too much makeup for me hard pack i
don't like the
i didn't mind what he was doing i hated
his persona
i hated the way he said he's cool off
here but i bet just
there's the whole affliction gear and
the the too many scarves and the [ __ ]
necklaces and is that an english accent
like what is the accent when i can't
tell what you're actually i heard
i heard in person he is dynamite really
i heard his show is fantastic
he just seems like a complete tool his
girl so hot
that's chris angel that's chris angel oh
he's really changed up his look
rightfully so yeah he looks like um
grillo
yes he does yeah he looks like frank
grillo yeah he looks good he got away
from like the [ __ ] boy like long hair
stuff
i mean i think at some point you do but
at least that was more emo
yeah like look at him there he's just
that's not the email every guy in hot
topic
yeah man you don't want to look like
joan james he's going through some [ __ ]
yeah he's better now i think anytime by
the way
i don't think if you're wearing a hoodie
with no shirt underneath you're better
i think you still hear it tom again i
heard his show is fantastic his show
people give him a lot of [ __ ] he's
fantastic he's been doing it forever
dude
i i don't have a problem with any comedy
that
anybody wants to do i really people are
buying tickets to it somebody's doing
something right but not only that man
like
here's the thing do you know for a long
time
i really one of the things that i really
wanted to do on stage because i
like to do it it makes me happy i do it
at my house
and beth was always like why don't you
do that on stage and i was like because
i know i'm going to get [ __ ] for it she
for years was like who cares doing what
at the end of my show i bring my guitar
oh and people are like oh that's hacking
yeah and i play
10 or 15 minutes i do an hour of stand
up and then do 10 or 15 minutes and she
was like
but you like it right and i said yeah
and she goes that means the people who
come to see you are going to like you
they like you
it took me so long so and carrot top man
look that's not what i do but i couldn't
make a tour
toy see what's going on i couldn't make
a toy helicopter funny
but i would like to see him start to
incorporate his dick
i wish he didn't get on all the steroids
he's jacked
and the botox and the i don't like how
chappelle's jacked
he's jacked anything weird when guys
like it's like they build this armor
because they're
they're like mean i i i have the
opposite issue they do
like they're real skinny and they want
to be real thick i'm thick and i won't
be skinny so it's like you always want
what you can't have
but but but why does he do you go
hairless do you shave it down no i don't
understand the shave it down part of it
like this dude play one of his videos
chin
i'd love to have him on here
let's reach out i love let me
check his schedule wide open
i love to i do love what he does like
he's past giving [ __ ]
what's on his face the mustache no like
the
hold on i think it's ketchup it's
supposed to be like his ears are
bleeding
oh gotcha that was freaking me out oh
his ears are bleeding top guy
glad i'm the only one who got the joke
yeah prop but his hair is
in mustache combo i haven't seen that
yet did he you know how much money that
tooth made
i guess he's worthy of 500 a gazillion
he's doing it right that's why who's not
this guy all right uh i'm out on a
saturday
cruising around on my scooter looking
for trouble and i saw this sign that
made me laugh
so i see this like what the hell it kind
of looks like it says herpes
herpes works here excuse me is herpes
here
yeah thomas brother valtrex it's yeah
valtrix here
there to see herpes thank you probably
not the best it's video for his uh for
his
time yeah my thing is if he's been if
you're doing it that long
at that level and selling those tickets
it might not be your cup of tea
just like just like train or just like
nickelback
isn't your no one likes people don't
respect him nickelback sold a [ __ ] ton
of records man
so although i might not like it they're
doing something that people [ __ ] with
dude
so i don't give a [ __ ] i agree i don't
get why people care
i do not care if carrick carrot tops
killing it no they'll take away from you
or bill bird
i don't know that's just his lame dude
yeah i it's the way i
like it's like when people hate on
nickelback it's like all right dude you
write a song that goes
global yeah don't oh but it's weak okay
that's
fine you write a song that goes global
you know
nickelback is like anal sex but it's
that easy it's like
nickelback is like anal sex it's always
fun well look
nobody wants to admit to liking it but
there's a lot of people doing it you
know what i mean like there's there that
it's not
not happening out there i i like i don't
think they're the best band ever
i don't give a [ __ ] if they go gold
platinum
somebody's listening to them why do they
get so much hatred like they're the butt
of every joke
i don't know i'm gonna tell you this i
like their music i have a couple
knickerback songs in my
yeah who else what other bands are like
that creed
creed yeah for sure because the way he's
saying too like oh that stuff
yeah but still all right you don't like
it
how many albums did create so i mean
they have to i don't remember
two of those hosted a super bowl
halftime show
they were big how they must have sold
dude they they were the biggest how many
tops
one album sold over 11 million dude is
so
crazy the group released the second
album
that is amazing
studio album's only four but they
released
18 singles off those four albums that's
a lot
that's a lot sold over 11 million albums
i i can't even so when people give guys
like groups like that a hard time
but again not my cup of tea but
something's
working this dude think about this
he was in this how crazy people are
kirktop nickelback and creed
on this episode this is how crazy this
is how crazy it is
this dude had arguably one of the
greatest music careers
there are there are he's in the definite
one percent of people who ever did his
job
but because people crushed him in his
band so much
about being creed didn't he like did he
jump off
he went building try to commit suicide
in miami oh did he i know he went crazy
a little bit and he did a video where he
was just like
freaking out on everything yeah he was
he was sad he was i mean he was
i think a heavy addict oh yeah but there
was
and so much of it i from what i
understand is just the [ __ ] he got
but man like isn't that crazy that
people that six that just shows you
yeah there you go that's what i was
talking about it just shows you like no
matter how successful
you think other people are i know
because that guy has all the money
he lives in a huge house pride is a
decent family
and then just it was too much wine it
was too much for him to take
i yeah i think it's but we went back to
it it's like what happened
with people giving chadwick bozeman [ __ ]
for being so skinny
ah people suck and you're like hey man
people suck
i i every picture because i'm like down
12 pounds over
every picture i post so like hey bro you
dying you think people would learn
i'm not dying man i'm just knocking the
gym comments on your picture
if you're losing weight and what yeah
why are you paying so much attention to
my
why are you keeping track of my [ __ ]
weight i suck by the way it's extra warm
in here today it's super oh yeah
it's 120 outside let me take a piss and
we'll do current eventually get out of
it before we all lose weight
what do you got all right so dr dre
is in the process of getting a divorce
from his
wife and she's asking for temporary
spousal support
and she asked for two million dollars a
month the judge asked
her to break down what the 2 million
would be
and this is her list close 135
laundry in cleaning 10 000 a month
entertainment 900
000 a month charity 125. wait telephone
cell phone email 20 20 000 a month
mortgage hundred thousand a month
hey brad where the [ __ ] are you living
what also entertainment
900 000 wait what's
what plan is is that the twenty thousand
a month cell phone plan
what plan is that let's be cricket i
mean what
what what what are you getting with the
twenty thousand a month plan like i have
so many questions with all of them okay
the only one that makes sense is the
charity 125 grand where you're like all
right or
guess if you're really charitable yeah
and to me the only thing that makes
sense
is the education you live in california
if you have more than one kid
i don't know how many six you have 60
grand a month you you you look you know
my kid goes to top private school you
would have to you'd have to have four or
five kids right at least
yeah tuition and living expenses dude
laundry ten grand yeah the judging can
look this way get the [ __ ] out but let
me ask you this
does mortgage does anybody
deserve two million a month in support
okay but it so for me it all depends
were you there with me when it started
when we were coming up like
so say i went to law school but my wife
supported me when i was in law school
and then i got to make sure you had a
house but she worked
while i was in law school so the only
reason i'm a lawyer
and could do that is because she worked
took care of the house
took care of me made the money i
couldn't make any money right sure
then you go on and become a lawyer and
make a [ __ ] ton of money
i do believe she's entitled because
you're not where she is
but let's say let's say we're we get
married in college yep i'm a first round
draft pick i get drafted
i go off and play yeah and then five
years down the road
you know i get my sunburst fighters down
the road you want two million a month
you weren't in the gym shooting with me
[ __ ] i agree with you 100
here's what i think i think if you have
kids
they should not they should not be
penalized so they should be able to keep
at least kind of quality of the life
because you shouldn't be
you shouldn't be like well dad's place
is so much better i never want to go
there
i never want to go to mom's place right
well here's it but that's what that's
what they're doing it's you got to
maintain the lifestyle right
so we're making fun of this but
you know he's a billionaire so in their
lifestyle might this might be their norm
where we see this like holy [ __ ] but
she's like nah [ __ ]
this is my life dude like we got to
maintain this but lifestyle to me makes
sense so say
i don't know where you live but if your
mortgage is 100 grand i don't
i can't imagine a mortgage at 100
a month like what is the the house must
be
apparently she's currently living in
their shared home in malibu i don't know
if that there's times
what to even at least like a hundred
grand
there there's a place in my neighborhood
that's renting renting
for 37 000 a month there's place in
malibu in the summer that will rent for
like 85 yeah but you're talking about
creme de la cre
when they're billionaires it's just a
different
life so this is normal to her but when
you break it down like that you look
like an [ __ ] you look like an
[ __ ] did you if you say to me hey i
want
1.9 a month because my kids are used to
living this way
i'm used to living this way this seems
but when you break it down
and you say hey i need 20 000 a month
for my cell phone
forget all that could you chill out on
the 900 grand
i know you yeah i can't get over how
could could you spend
so say i'm like i'm gonna give you 900
you have to spend 900 000 a month
on entertainment we're playing yeah i
can spend it because we're flying first
class everywhere
okay not first not first class we're
flying private private's expensive dude
but does that fall under
entertainment i guess oh yeah so so say
you want to pick you want to take me
and three and a squad to miami for a
show okay
what's the private plan gonna cost you
probably 120
is it that much well you could do like
the least thing which i'm not doing
right my man is dr drake so you could do
like the least thing
but that's still like 40 g's but 120
gets you a [ __ ]
g ass private yeah
i guess i guess dude i guess because you
would have to try
i would have to literally at the
beginning of every month if you said
here's
here's 900 thousand dollars you have to
spend on entertainment 20 so yeah so
what i say 40.
new york city to money though 20 grand
one way
you would have to fly private all but
that's all she knows dude you got to
maintain my lifestyle but but but but if
you're if you're spending 900 000
entertainment
what do you need 100 000 for a mortgage
you're never home
because you have to go do [ __ ] for the
nine unless unless you're hiring i'm
gonna hire john mayer to come over and
cook my dinner yeah
like you know what they're doing she's
shooting for the moon hopefully
land on the stars and get like a million
if you
it's insane if you were married to dr
dre
yeah or say you're married to the rich
like a real rich
woman and you're gonna hit me like you
did his previous wife
uh man is it worth two million for you
you can hit me
you can beat me around
i think for two mil you can slap me
around i'm taking a punch for two
minutes i'll slap you
yeah i don't mind yeah i don't know i'll
take a spank to the ass
mr dre but what what well like it
what are you asking what do you what
like are you getting
a million of it but it's just all
perspective yeah like i'm sure if we
broke down your monthly bills you break
down my monthly bills
nowhere near this but to a certain
people they're like what the [ __ ] you
spend that on
shoes yeah or you know whatever it is
like you spend on post baits like yeah
dude
that's true it's just it's all like
there's certain levels man
but this is this is insane either way
it's so blind
to just what's happening in america
right now but
not to defend her but to her perspective
like she came with dr dre he's a
straight up
billionaire yeah so she's like this
ain't [ __ ] dude is two million a month
anything to a billionaire that's 24
million a year
what's what's 24 million percentage-wise
to a billion well
it's a billion point two hundred hundred
millions right
it's so much money no it's like a
thousand it's a thousand something
million right a billion a billion is a
hundred
wait a hundred million so a billion is a
hundred
right it's one thousand million one
thousand so that's just
this that doesn't do anything 24 million
i mean that kind of money to me is not
even
it it doesn't compute which is
everything's free so
to to that like like class isn't
affected
i think if i had a billion dollars i
don't think there's any doubt
that everybody that shares my last name
would be set up everyone no you're right
there's a couple people yeah yeah but
most people set up but i think
i would have so much fun you know one of
the things that puma did for me
be which i love one of my favorite
things to do you give it a billion
dollars no i wish
but they used to give me all these shoes
and and they would say drive around la
because i would say can i drive around
la and just hand them out to people and
they're like yeah that sounds like a lot
of fun just filming that's cool
so we would drive around we'd find
people who obviously live in wherever
and we'd hand our shoes
if i had a billion dollars i would do
that with money really
a hundred percent get robbed but you
probably hire i mean
i'm i'm going around with something now
you know they're selling those pumas for
meth right that's fine yeah whatever i
mean you know
except there were some people who's
legit crying
there were guys i was like what size
shoe are you and i remember when i
walked up this one guy i'm like what's
that shoe you
and he goes eight to ten and i was like
what he goes well i'm a size 10
but i can squeeze into a size eight if
they're new
and i said what are you wearing right
now he said eight and
his toes jam-packed and
when i i was like here's a size size 10.
and he wouldn't take him he was like
what
what does that mean like what do i have
to i'm not going to suck you off yeah
well i have to do i'm like no these are
free
shoes and he was like i haven't worn a
pair of shoes
that were my size and i can't remember
and he put him on
he you know what he did too which was
run off he he ran like they made him
remember when you used to put on new
shoes and you were down you're like yeah
yeah he ran up and down in front of
ralph's a couple times he's like these
feel good i'm like alright dude check
chill out chill out yeah but yeah dude
um i mean i imagine if you're homeless
you wear a size
16. oh you're out that's just like
there's no
there's no uggs not unless shaq is
driving around
those when shaq had a pair of shoes up
at jerry's deli that bowling place in
the valley it's
crazy how big his foot is it's not seven
footer dude 400 pounds
were you the one who said tiny dick well
that's the rumor i don't spread it
you already did though i mean is that i
just
that is so [ __ ] big it's
kind of banana it's nuts i i
have you ever stood like i met when he
was alive in an airport and i was a very
young person i met andre the giant
and so we shook well his hands are so
big
my i remember i was such a tiny person i
think i was 10.
it's almost a bummer to be that big
it's got they said it was like his
joints like he was in pain
24 7. and buddy i mean planes were at
night
he would drink planes he was a case of
wine because his joints are so bad he
would drink before playing right now i
wouldn't want to be at nightmare
i wouldn't have any cool clothes cars
you're pushing up against this
too big yeah i agree like i could hear
that dude
look at that that was me and ralphie
millions
by the way and then i was the small guy
he's playing too small
right i was like that's offensive if he
sits on the plane
i'm going to ask the flight attendant
like is he balancing it out like
how do we balance out that's a real can
what else you guys got
it's definitely cooler here with that
door open so much better even if the
audio sucks it's almost worth it
so on wednesday a canadian doctor came
out and
recommends that we all avoid kissing new
people and if
we want to have sex to have sex with a
mask on to prevent the spread of covet
19.
and furries are like i told you
[ __ ] and that's her and put out
a bunny outfit makes sense
yeah maybe that makes sense
yeah i think it was probably her husband
who was like maybe you should try the
mask are you easy with me no just
covering your face
what you covered what about covering
your
face and putting a wig on
did i tell you what my wife this is how
honest we're getting in my house
we were having sex because covet has
made you extremely honest with your
partner
we were having sex and she was on top of
me and she just looked down at me and
she goes
man your face is really bothering me
tonight look that way and i go what
oh wow she was like i don't like it it's
so stupid look that way oh wow my dick
could have went
see ya yeah i was just like okay well
i'm not lit i'm not you're well
i'm still in it you're still good i'm
not i'm not quitting that'll hurt my
feelings
nah my dick would have like you know
what we're taking our ball and we're
going
it hurt my feelings after yeah that
makes sense she was like it was so dumb
i had a real dumb face that's hilarious
what else you got
uh that's not it oh what
this is a gangster move well that was
jim brought up his own reading
oh uh hey check it out
uh korean lady pee's on people
yeah some [ __ ] or no you're looking at
you i did read this
oh check it out uh creole likes to pee
on children why is there a picture of a
waterfall in a peeing story
i think that was like she peed on a
futon it was a i think it was a guy and
then he was just
drinking and i guess the students for
some reason they're doing something
where they're staying together and then
he just opened up the door and peed on
their futon or where would it whatever
japanese style thing yeah
his buzz bringing this up huh yeah
yeah was it one of those was it one of
those situations
where because i've had friends who were
so drunk they went to sleep so drunk and
they got up in the middle of the night
oh yeah and they thought they were going
to the bathroom and they pee in the
closet like it wasn't
oh this was a little tough i mean you're
probably not you shouldn't be drinking
at least three were awoken in the middle
of the night by one of their coaches
taking a piss on one of their futons
also is this newsworthy no no that's why
this was i know i'm just saying but like
who would write an article
counting a six pack in an hour and a
half is bound to make you sleepy and the
coach dozed off
yeah right sometimes it happens 50's
just do this thing
all right this one so a couple days ago
a photo of rihanna with
a uh kind of like beaten up face
got onto the internet and they thought
that something happened again
chris brown made an appearance yeah but
it turns out she actually got
into a electric scooter accident where
she
basically ate [ __ ] i i do want to amend
the scooter i said selma hayek to me was
far and away number one
that's this is a close second have you
seen a person yes
she's super strong oh my god you know
what else adds to her sexiness is how
[ __ ] confident she is oh i think you
say [ __ ]
that does it for me i like when you walk
in like
i am the head [ __ ] in charge i'm
like yeah you are she's such a baddie
oh my god she's still dating that prince
i
think they broke tough to compete with
like a saudi prince there's no
what do you offer nothing what i mean
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
say i can cook you a meal
like i don't there's nothing there's
nothing you can because they have
unlimited
access to funds yes and everything
i have always been oh my god yeah i'm a
huge
do you do you um are you serena williams
fan at all
yeah why okay i mean not only do i think
that she's
you're too light in the ass for it bubba
i think so yeah have you ever seen her
in person i have
a big girl i am a human for me i'd have
to like
i might have to stretch oh i'm a big fan
oh i'm a fan too
i'm a big i've seen her man now
i mean he's taller but he's pretty light
in the ass she's
she's she's oh dude think i think she's
she's gorgeous far away gorgeous and but
i think she's also
um in my lifetime ooh could i find a
close second
the most dominant athlete out there i'm
interesting
maybe jordan but oh interesting very
interesting but i think
she without a doubt is the most i'm
trying to think
because i'm doing this on the floor
right as far as men djokovic
i think she's got to be the most
dominant athlete
lewis hamilton lewis hamilton okay
for the extended period that she's been
dominant
i take in the competition dude but
that's not her fault
but that's why she's not in my race but
she's beat everybody
her sister who her sister when her
sister came in there like she was like
oh she's gonna be the best
she's the most and and is
let me ask you this is it that her
competition
or she's that good competition who who
do you think if you go
most down an athlete since you've been
alive who tops her in what she's done
uh a joke of it she's just playing at a
higher level lance armstrong
more dominant lamps are strong more
dominant
like how many times he won dude dude
she's
look how many times she's won level
competition but but i don't know
i don't know about the tour de france
and i don't so i don't front see that
accident
i don't know about his competition
either tiger woods
is uh i listen to tiger woods
but yeah tiger might be
tiger woods dominated
but serena brady too many other people
but again also tom brady to be to go to
that many super bowls in a team sport
in that period of time who do you
oh hussein bolt is he on that list who's
saying this
mike michael johnson usain bolt what's
this
uh 10 most dominant athletes who's
number one so serena tiger who's saying
who's number one
yeah by far okay but i don't know
michael phelps's level competition too
but i don't know that enough about
swimming it was the olympics so he's
taking the best in the world
of swimmers so what you mean you're not
saying level of competition for the
sport you mean the level of
athlete how many people are
participating like uh
like to me like ronaldo or messi would
be
the hot think of many people play soccer
now these
these guys are the best of the best out
of the millions of people that play
messi's the very top echelon guy and
dominating
right now how many female tennis players
are there in the world
and are the best athletes playing tennis
okay so now
now i know what you mean by level of
competition that's what i mean not that
they're not that she's not playing the
ball no she's fantastic not that she's
not playing the best who are playing but
just like
the best athletes may not be playing
that sport
so the best we're the best the the world
play soccer
messi's the number one player same with
basketball like
the best athletes are playing like when
you're when you're playing in the nfl at
wide receiver
the best athletes so that's yeah that i
had that's what i'm talking about so
you're not you're not talking about this
these people don't know how to play
you're saying
saying there could have been dominance
over this mass amount of
other players who are so talented and
they're dominating so like trout where
do you put that's ridiculous
where do you put floyd mayweather in
that because he was dominant but
but are you do you think the best
athletes are boxing right now no
no way no way right so on that list
who was the first non but they're
dominant
who was the first non like playing by
themself
player like who put the first person to
play on a team so the first team player
was lebron
to be the most dominant tom brady and
brady but how come jordan's not in there
barry bonds i could put in there that's
really interesting man i hadn't thought
about that
and by the way if you're just saying
dominant i might put shaq
above any other basketball player
because he truly was
unstoppable when he wan when he was on
the magic
in early lakers when that dude wanted
to be the best it was not even close
yeah it's weird because then they're
also
putting olympics above other sports as
far as winning
gold medal but how many kids are
swimming
but in other countries how many kids are
swimming but in other countries where
they don't have a lot of pro sports you
know what they're doing
playing soccer yes but they're also
there are in other countries tennessee's
big swimming pools
tennis is the most expensive yep yep i
forgot about that money to skiing those
are
so expensive so it's like the lev the
talent pool it's like who's doing that
now they're dominant doing it but who to
you you think messi or ronaldo oh for
sure
100 and who do you think the most
dominant team sport player
brady in the 21st century
and i the only reason you know i'm a
brady fan because he's winning
but he's i don't think he's as
singularly
i'm gonna find out i know but then his
team on tampa stat
and they just signed fournette insane
i feel bad for running backs by the way
i feel bad for
the campaign buccaneers because now it's
like yo you have to if you don't win the
super bowl you guys get made fun of by
the way
it's like you stack the box too much
what's not being talked about is
their defense was legit last year if
they don't win can't believe the nfl's
playing on thursday dude
i had no [ __ ] idea it's a problem i'm
blown away by that that's a problem
a full schedule slate of games
nuts do you where do you think ratings
are gonna be
because people are kneeling dude a
hundred percent
better oh dude above basketball oh yeah
below golf
well that golf like the phil mickelson
tiger woods paint man tom brady things
like the most
watched something thing in like all time
so
definitely below that in pandemic times
did you what excuse me you watched bill
and ted yeah you're not watching that
hard pass
you didn't watch the original bill and
ted's oh the originals yeah but the
older stuff like did you watch dumb and
dumb earth
no why would you do that you can't do
that you can't beat
what it was when i heard they were
making a remake of goonies
ah disgusting hey you know they're
making plain strains of automobiles
but with kevin hart and uh
tell me it's the rock those two will
smith i'm in for that sign me huh by the
way i'm in for that i had a buddy go you
believe they're redoing them like well
who's in it yes
kevin hart will smith went holy [ __ ]
that sounds fantastic
they're both kevin that's gonna be great
the original plane's training
classic the original my mom's favorite
movie the
you're going the wrong way great movie
how does he know which way we're going
it's great
it is one of the has so many quotable
lines those aren't two pillows john
candy
when people don't talk about him as one
of the great
comedic actors that dude if you look at
his list
of movies that that guy was in steve
martin too man oh my god
what else you guys got give me one more
i'm so hot okay
um here you go uh just a quick one
carol baskin is gonna be on dancing with
the stars this upcoming season did it
weird her celebrity even though she
killed her husband
yeah it's a weird thing for her to be
famous
over i'd assume she gets voted out right
is it
is it weird i mean you know where we
live right
pete we love that [ __ ] we love we
i don't see her dance i mean you i don't
want to see any of those [ __ ]
damn i mean either
the dancing with the stars the idea of
the show is somebody basically said hey
stars is a very loose
loose term they basically said hey let's
get a bunch of people together that
nobody cares about
uh and let's get them and put them on
the show and have them do something
that normally we wouldn't watch anybody
else do and they were like good
what's weird to me is they had kim
kardashian on their shoes voted off
first
it just shows you like instagram
followers and twitter followers don't
equal real life because otherwise she
would have won every [ __ ] but that's
not who's voting
well i'm just saying like your fan base
is aware she's doing it exactly
that's is that this year i think so yeah
let's take a look who we got i saw nelly
in there somewhere
anybody good backstreet boys who was the
super bowl champion that was on there no
i
don't know the kid the guy from captain
charles oakley is oakley
i miss oak man i'm mo i missed
a very loose term celebrity yeah jesse
metcalf
oh vernon davis is coming on oh i saw uh
uh nick carter the his brother the guy
very clear
in porno now i think with the girl that
he uh accused of domestic violence
yeah they're doing porno now i did a one
of a very early early internet show
about the carters because they used to
have a reality show on e
oh it's fantastic and so then we did an
after show me and a therapist
it might have been called meet the
carters i completely forget whatever it
is
sounds fantastic when we did a deep dive
into this family
they're so [ __ ] up yeah oh my god dude
i'm not surprised that this guy the
after show isn't doing well
i'm not surprised because he was there
look how that's
that's an the house of carters oh
remember they fought
that was the first reality show where i
was like oh this is
it was so [ __ ] crazy four out of 10
imbd come on
oh no no you're not watching with good
eyes that was the
that was a train wreck and a half the
house of carters
because they were trying the best is
watching people trying to keep it
together
trying to keep their [ __ ] together but
it was so toxic and then finally nick
and aaron
fight it's it's good tv it's great tv
if you don't yeah it's great now the the
the dollar died oh deep come on
one of the one of the hang sisters up on
youtube when they fight and
we'll we'll get out of here after that
it's fantastic they fight on tv
is that you can tell it's real because
the the cameras they shut out
what's your favorite internet fight
you've ever seen
probably this is it this is pretty good
this is a good one
[Music]
oh here we go
[Music]
this is pre-meth
yeah but let me tell you something
really like this here it is you're gonna
turn the music down
and respect me hey right in my face all
right all right in my face
baby let's go
are there no scenes no don't
because when i broke up with paris this
guy takes her out
and tries the next day i find phone in
the car
and who is it it's his phone taking a
picture of her
her smiling like this in my in my
catalog
but i never did anything with her i
never touched that
yeah it was really by the way they had
the osborne's on as well the osborne's
were great because
they should have had the fact that did
you see the new article on that
no i mean i can't belie like there's no
way ozzy osbourne would have a show
today
if people dug up his history because
there was a time when uh he got arrested
for domestic violence he was all high
and attacked share and tried killing her
like the demons in his head were telling
the killer
it's like oh you can't be on tv dude by
the way that was
like well known then i know like there's
no way they're green light a show with
ozzy osbourne now
well i mean cancel culture like uh nope
but then there he might get a pass
because he snorted ants
they still want to do it like the kanto
culture would stop it before they would
show like
premier in the night you'd get canceled
before it started guys like that
i love that kind of weird [ __ ] the the
nick carter aaron carter
dynamic because
nick look he had to have what do you
think 35
pounds on him oh big brother yeah at
least 35
but he also like was a bit of a [ __ ]
about that
at the end older one yeah yeah do you
know what i mean we got real that's
i like it when it got real yeah a bit of
a it's a it's a bummer that they're not
like close but also who cares but
that's wrong but also i don't but also
i don't give a flying [ __ ] but also
i wish it
[Music]
uh you can check comedianjoshwolf.com
for shows but also guys
my patreon patreon patreon went up today
it's patreon.com forward slash or slash
josh wolfe comedy are you gonna do the
hi
i'm gonna do a hot extra high live on
there um and my
solo podcast will be exclusive on
patreon so if you want to hear a solo
podcast
that's exclusive on there i'm also you
i'm going to be sending people
we can do private zooms on mine and i
can send you personal videos it's all
pants on
uh just or is it well you know we'll
have only one way to find that only fans
[ __ ]
uh but it's uh patreon.com four slash
josh wolfe comments oh tight move man
uh i'm supposed to be in austin the end
of the month i know they refunded guys
tickets because as of this week they
had austin shut them down but yeah they
said they're they might be coming back
so i'll keep you guys posted about
austin but one thing for sure i know is
happening
is dallas october 1st through the 3rd
and nashville november 19th through the
21st
but i'll keep you posted on austin we're
going to try and make it happen
nashville
can i get to guess that i'm going to be
oh yeah 100 let's do it i won't be down
there for sure yeah let's do that
brother that'd be fun
all right that's it love you guys